with blood and rage of crimson red
ripped from a corpse so freshly dead
together with our hellish hate will burn
you all this is your fate welcome to the
weekly poll I'm Benny Potter from the
comic storian Channel and this is my
usual crew of mly Red Lanterns you're
all Angry be
angry okay
we're not a very angry crew of Red
Lanterns we're the softer Red
Lanterns all right as usual I'm from
comic storian the link will be in the
description down below and we're over in
the sidebar over here at Marvel
explained um we're on Marvel explained
you guys all know Rob so I'm gonna cut
you off this week Rob and let Dave
introduce himself and our special guest
s all right
Dave start Dave start go go all right so
uh I'm for Channel called Comics reviews
I just started uh I've got two videos in
total so far I'm planning out the next
three or
four but uh I I go into more like
product oriented view on comic books uh
I review the quality of things like the
print uh you know and also I I do a
little Spiel on how it is for somebody
getting into Comics to say collect Civil
War which I'm working on right now
appropriately when Rob is doing his
Civil War oh that's conveniently timed
almost like we planned this kind of
thing
right it's almost like I want to get all
Rob's
[Laughter]
viewers all right s go do your Spiel so
then Rob can introduce himself and
explain what we just did absolutely hi
everybody I am s I'm from a channel
called TV Little House youtube.com/
little house uh we do a slew of Pop
inspired shows most of them comic book
related which is why I'm here and uh or
at least why they brought me here uh
from a far away dimension of obscurity
and uh the shows that uh we produce are
off the rack which are Monday Tuesday
and Wednesday where myself and my two
cohorts Ben and Ethan review a book off
the rack from the week prior um we each
read the book and then we give our
opinion and we try to keep it under 10
minutes just to because we know you have
no time and we don't have any time so
you know we try to make that really bite
size and easy to easy to digest the show
we come out on Thursdays is called back
issues where the two guys who I just
just uh explained and I talk about
either a character or a story arc that I
remember or that I like read and own um
because the the hook is that the two
guys that I hang out with and who are
sharing space with me on the show uh
don't read Comics they just they they
never grew up with them they don't read
them now um but they have a fascination
with them because they're friends with
me and they they kind of don't
understand why I like them so much so uh
we sit down and I kind of explain these
stories or characters to them and then
they kind of go like what and they ask
me questions that we as a community just
don't ask because we've kind of drank
the Kool-Aid as far as being comic book
fans like we don't ask like so there are
other L red orange yellow why like that
doesn't make any sense and we're just
like because it's cool because it's the
because the Spectrum like the emotional
Spectrum yeah we're like it's the
emotional spectrum and that and we buy
it but they're like that doesn't make no
uh so and it actually winds up really
inspiring some really terrific
conversations and uh I find that it
helps bring in people who either don't
read Comics casually read Comics or love
Comics because all uh sides of that
Spectrum uh find something they can
enjoy about the show so that's that's
our show back issues we also do a video
game review show called bonus round uh
old school gamer meets new School gamer
and then explains and makes uh the new
school gamer play through old games
before level design before Game Theory
it was the wild west of of games so
that's called bonus round you can check
that out that comes out on a bi-weekly
basis um and we also review collectibles
on a show called busted but that's like
two episodes and so we're just we're
just kind of getting our feet wet with
that good stuff man good stuff thank you
um all right so as you guys know as you
guys know with the weekly pool podcast
we have discussions about all kinds of
things and we have all kinds of opinions
here usually Benny won't let you get a
word in edgewise while he's talking or
while he has a point to make I don't
know what you're talking about I didn't
C Dave Dave never talks you know it we
have so many different things go on
here but find out what your Trope is
going to be sound I'm just here to be a
pretty
face but but as you guys know the first
part of of our weekly pool podcast is
the debate that we have when we talk
about two two characters that go against
each other um this week it was azreel
from DC and Spider-Man from a superior
Spider-Man who was the Dr Octopus
Spider-Man from Marvel Comics and it was
uh it was actually s and Benny this time
it was actually a really cool discussion
because I didn't know anything about
Azrael and what I learned is that he
pretty much sucks so
um it was really no see now you just
spoiled it though he no he does suck was
amazing you guys should go watch that it
I it was it was a really entertaining
video and it was it was a it was a
really cool discussion but um but
keeping with the whole thing keep you
know because s's our guest and s's here
you know to to um you know be on this
week's weekly pool podcast we really
kind of want to keep this theme going
with with what he has on his channel and
coming book discussions and whatnot so
we're going to talk about um the current
run of original sin the new update that
came out this week came out yesterday of
course we're going to talk about
Guardians of the Galaxy coming up uh
we're going to talk about the new Flash
TV TV show and then we might do some
touching on maybe some past you know
video games and maybe some a really good
story line from the Marvel Comics um all
right now here's my question because I
was thinking about this when when um s
was talking about like you know Past
comic book story lines um the House of M
like I know Dave hasn't read the House
of M yet oh you in your house of M my my
my subscribers my subscribers have been
screaming at me about the House of M
like we want the House of M by God don't
bring kill you
haven't they all
demanded okay okay 11,000 scre house I
think it's one guy and Rob's just like
that one guy talks a lot I better do
House of M I mean okay 11,000 people are
not simultaneously screaming House of M
but there is enough Demand on my channel
for the House of M that I figured it'd
make a good discussion plus it was a
really good story so I mean if you guys
are down I'm down we're talking about
the house of him sure so cool right now
no no not right now I mean we'll get to
the house of him later we're going to do
the Flash TV show yeah we're going to do
the Flash TV show of course we're going
to do the Flash TV show I've only
prepped for
that all right so so actually so
watching The Flash TV show it was kind
of what I expected to a degree I mean I
knew that it was a pilot going in and
most Pilots aren't of like the highest
caliber product I mean people are really
just kind of getting comfortable with
the characters they're portraying and
the writers are still kind of hashing
out the story and some of the writers
are still hashing out their own writing
style so like it's it's kind of what I
expected there was a little bit of
corniness to it it was like maybe
watching Agents of Shield but overall it
wasn't bad but for the most part when it
terms when it comes to like the origins
of the flash like I defer to Benny on
this because I don't know the origins of
The Flash in you know in in in DC and i'
would also defer to S so s are you're
familiar with the flash like I I am uh I
not to the degree that any DC fan is
because I'm more of a Marvel guy but I
read DC back in the like back in my day
yeah um so I'm familiar like I know that
Barry Allen sacrificed himself to save
the Multiverse uh I know that Wally West
took over I know there have been like
five or six flashes in in this uh within
that time um I know that uh Jeff Johns
has a real hard on for Barry Allen which
is why he's back and uh I won't even
deny that he definitely does have a
heart on for bar yeah um we got four
flash but you know what let's revive
that one that died in the 80s yeah I
want to write for Flash but I want to
write about the one that I like and not
the one that's going on right now that's
why in Justice League doomed uh that
really cool movie that DC made where it
was like a adaptation of uh Justice
League Tower of Babel yeah um they got
the whole cast from or more or less the
whole cast from the old Justice League
and Justice League Unlimited cartoon to
do the voices but they changed Wally
West to Barry Allen because Jeff JNS is
in charge and he's like well but make it
Barry Allen well here here here's a
problem with that though and this is my
biggest issue with with the Jeff John's
change over in Barry Allen Barry Allen
is almost an anagram of Wally West and
Barry Allen at this point yeah because
pre crisis Barry Allen was more of a
serious character he had occasional
oneliner but he wasn't anywhere near
like he is now now he's the jokester of
the Justice League he makes the jokes he
makes the jokes in the TV show he makes
the jokes in the new 52 they've pretty
much taken what Wally West was and just
named him Barry Allen yeah and made the
original flash comeback so now there's
no real reason to bring in Wally West
although I think they have now he's like
blue or something no no no no no now
Wally West is a like 15-year-old black
kid oh okay cool that that's like a
they're rebooting every it sounds like
he's been New
52 he has been New 52 they're like it
was okay side note real quick I've been
following 52 and I've got my hard
problems with it and one of the biggest
issues I had was they have to introduce
all the characters so we didn't have um
uh Stephanie Brown we didn't have her
back yet and we didn't and she's back
now we have spoiler but we we finally
got Wally West but we didn't get Wally
West to we all know jokester guy
sometimes red hair sometimes brown hair
very white guy that we've all come to
know and love and I'm fine with
rebooting in a different direction but
the way DC did it was by the way here's
Wy West he's also black and he's 15 now
and you're just kind of
like okay yeah all right that's not
really Wally West you could have named
him anybody but
okay
yeah he's also angry all the time now he
doesn't crack any jokes oh and hates
Barry Allen because Barry Allen is
dating his mom or something like that oh
sure so yeah so we don't like
personality wise he's not even the same
Wally West he's literally Wally West in
name only yeah and that's it that sounds
n you got as you put it new 52 yeah blue
flashes is actually Barry Island from
the future coming back in time to kill
off people because he discovered basic
we all know the superhero TR why do you
put them in jail just kill them they're
always going to break out right Barry
Allen what we're seeing in the current
story line has discovered that to be the
fact and in the future his whole life
went to crap and everyone died because
he's been doing that so he's now going
back in time and he's killing off all
the villains before they can possibly
cause an issue yeah because Barry Allen
going back in time never backfires no
never well all right new vitude
exactly so here is here's my question
involving like The Flash TV
show who the hell was the guy
yellow oh that's aard [__] Thor right
like that's the that's reverse flash
we've got multiple reverse flashes and
I'm going to go ahead and say the new 52
reverse flash is not reverse flash oh
okay if you've seen him the new 52
reverse flash is a guy who's got a monor
real train strapped to his
body and he's not even a thorn he's um
he's W he's he's Iris West's like long
lost brother oh totally different
character totally different plot and
they're like like but he's reverse flash
but now he's reverse flash yeah yeah
okay okay so the plot with Barry Allen
this is what I loved about that TV show
the actual plot that they've recently
they've always okay the the whole core
of Barry Allen is his mother dies and
it's it's an unsolved mystery it always
has been they've never really gone into
it his father Goes to Jail to take the
blame for it that is the plot of Barry
Allen now what happens with Barry Allen
is he then grows up joins the CSI
because he wants to solve Unsolved
Mysteries and figure out happened to his
mom as being in the lab one night late
night he was there working late um he's
standing next to a counter of chemicals
and a bolt of lightning comes through
hits the chemicals explodes them they
spill all over him and he gets the
powers of the flash right so the whole
core plot to the flash is the fact that
he because of his mother's death he's in
the right place and the right time to
become the flash right now reverse flash
I don't you want to to because you seem
to know also s do you know reverse flash
is history uh the history as far as I
recall is that the reverse flash is from
the future yes and he is a result of
Barry Allen becoming the flash which is
to say that like without Barry Allen
becoming the flash there is no reverse
flash um I don't know necessarily what
the connection like it's basically is it
the lightning bolt or is it like some
kind of I I'm not sure where he got his
powers I think it was just an experiment
because he's the like 25th Century it's
like crazy far in I think he just gave
himself to him and his goal was to be he
always idolizes The Flash and that's
what gives him the idea to become
reverse flash that's what his problem
comes in if there is no flash he never
gets the idea to become flash reverse
flash and I don't exactly know the full
story because it happened like way way
way back in the day when it first first
happened yeah but for whatever the
reason he goes back in time to make
flash suffer right he's got a problem
with the Flash and I don't fully know
why but his but his Hook is he can never
kill the flash because if he does then
the flash will never
Inspire him to become reverse flash
exactly so so it's an always a thing
which is why in the flasho event reverse
flash gets removed from the timeline and
is finally free to kill the flash
exactly only to be killed by Thomas
Wayne
but um so the character in the movie now
what ends up happening and this is what
we finally discovered in flasho the full
story of Barry Allen's mother's death
yeah reverse flash goes back in time and
he thinks the best way he can get the
flash is by killing the Flash's mother
but as we discover is reverse flash goes
back in time flash chases him back in
time and then in order to stop reverse
flash he like misses and kills his own
mother that and I think they're going
with that plot because in the TV show we
have the yellow blur and we have a very
prominent red blur following him so yeah
so I'm pretty sure they're going to go
with that but what it comes down to is
his mother can't survive he can't sa her
because if he does nothing happens the
way it's supposed to and that's actually
how the the flasho event happens yeah he
goes back he changes that and it changes
so many things just from his mother
living right huh now see that's
interesting to me because like in the
past we've talked about time travel in
comic books and how like more often than
not time travel is used is just kind of
like oh my God we've written ourselves
up against the wall let's just send this
guy back in time and fix the problem
like you know Age of Ultron kind of
thing so yeah um but that's that's
really yeah like that's that's really
kind of cool to me that the that the
flash is in effect like the cause of his
own future like he's he's the reason why
he exists and to me like that's that's
really kind of interesting because when
I was watching the trailer and they had
that you know whole scene going on and
the blurs and all that kind of stuff
like when I saw the red blur I knew
right off the bat okay that's that's
obviously flash so the question was like
who's the yellow guy and I figured that
there was because I remember you talking
before when you talked about like the
whole flasho series and the Flash
jumping back in time and all that kind
of stuff and I said okay well this is
probably what's going on here I really
wasn't sure how to make the connection
between like you know the whole Flash
and whoever the yellow guy was and then
you know his mom but to me it made sense
that most likely the flash for some
reason had a hand in it or just wasn't
able to stop the guy from killing his
mom and it resulted in like the flash
becoming who he was but um well the
whole thing with the verse Flash is he
always tries to do things that will mess
with the flash yeah right and so but he
can only do things that are only already
supposed to happen so I I don't fully
know exactly what was happened but he
was back in time to basically kill his
mom in like the most painful way
possible he knew she was going to die
anyway but he wanted to make it like
really painful and the Flash would know
he did it that kind of a thing okay man
yeah I mean that's that's kind of [__]
up you know I mean that would be a
really like crappy thing to to be a
villain like that yeah like oh man like
this is supposed to happen I guess I
have to go do this now well what
happening is he goes back in time the
first time and for the flas point event
and he like kills reverse flash by
mistake so reverse flash doesn't kill
his mom and that's what sets things off
in the bad motion so when he goes back
in time he has to stop himself from
stopping Thorn and watching his mom get
killed by Thorn yeah okay yeah you know
that they're gonna oh God no no you were
saying so I was gonna say you know
they're going to do an episode where
like there was some suppressed evidence
that show that like Barry Allen's
fingerprints were like at the scene of
the murder of his mom they're gonna yeah
they're gonna have to I guarantee
they're going to build up for exactly
what we just said or something very
similar I'm really excited to see if
they're going to go that full thing
because jumping through the whole
episode and we'll come back to more
stuff in the episode but you guys saw
the little basically the whole season
prep ending right y so my question is Mr
I'm pretending to be in a wheelchair by
the way uh for the record if you haven't
watched this episode this probably isn't
the the podcast to listen to I'm just
yeah after we spoiled like so much of
what's probably gonna happen like
spoiler
alert went back in time and we watched
the show
so we're going through with a scalpel on
this episode so well I mean it's it's
fun for me cuz I'm I don't read DC so
like like this is all new to me so it's
it's really fascinating like it's it's
and just like when we discussed Age of
Ultron we may be way off they might do
this totally different Direction with
this whole thing yeah so um but what if
you go to the ending I'm curious and St
since you know a little more about this
do you think he's reverse flash or do
you think he's searching something else
uh do I think that wheelchair guys
reverse flash yeah the guy who played
like Ed or something way back in the day
I I
think I mean he looks intelligent he
could be yeah I feel
like I it's a CW Show so they naturally
assume that we're all morons I feel like
I feel like they think that it's enough
for
thawn the new guy on the force who is
iris's
boyfriend uh is reverse flash that he
went back in time he killed the mom and
then he in and then he's integrated
himself into Barry Allen's life working
at his job banging his future wife
and that'll be enough I think for them
to for them to go like yeah that's
reverse flash now I don't know what
they're doing with with wheelchair guy
or if he's like a future version of him
I don't know I well it's weird because
he has the paper from the future that
says and here's what I flipped out about
hold on hold on hold on I'm sorry I got
to stop you we need to back
up to what to all right the new cop on
the force is the future
I'm confused I'm confused as hell on the
force is is current negative for reverse
flash reverse flash I mean bear in
mindar in
mind be the same person from the future
oh God hold on they might be pulling the
same crap they did from Arrow if you
remember the first season of Arrow
Deathstroke and Slade were different
people until Slade put on the mask and
you're like oh he's death
stroke I uh I saw the first three
episodes of Arrow well the whole first
season of Arrow you find out that Slade
is is a part of like he's a buddies with
another mercenary and they both wear the
mask so technically Deathstroke is this
other guy so Slade is the friend to
Arrow the whole first season okay and
then in the second season he puts the
mask on to get revenge against Arrow
right so that's why I'm I'm kind of
wondering if we're gonna retread the
same thing what if thawn becomes like
his buddy like this is finally what
thawn wants cuz I do remember the
originally he went back in time because
he wanted to be like friends with flash
or something like that that's why he
went back and Flash did something to
piss him off I don't remember what right
H see that's that's crazy to me so so
thwn goes back in time kills his mom and
then reintegrates himself once he is
more or less like a young adult as a
member of the police
force that's that's
crazy never it makes her a really good
story but you know he never does go back
back home he the whole time he's back at
the pass of Barry Allen and all them
okay it's kind of like Booster Gold you
know Booster Gold goes back in time for
his own like prosperity and fame thawn
goes back in time to do something with
the flash ends up being pissed and he
just stays there to [__] with the flash
yeah and then and every time they catch
him they always turn like they always
put him in like this giant Contraption
turn him upside down and like wow well
see that would make wow that would make
for a really good plot element because
then like so I assume that Barry Allen I
mean obviously Barry Allen doesn't know
what's going on at the moment all he
knows is that there's just some guy
who's banging the chick that he wants to
bang and he's just kind of upset about
it and wow okay see see that's that's
really cool to me like that would make
because you could build so much out of
that like you could just really kind of
because obviously you know with people
who read DC like you guys are aware of
who this guy is and what he's going to
be or what he already is and you know
where he comes from so it would it would
create for great storytelling because
now you can watch that on baited breath
and see where are they going to take it
are they going to follow the comic book
story line and people like me who don't
know and who were like totally surprised
by like wow you know what's going on
here like you can follow it and be just
as anxious as everybody else so that's I
just got a premonition I know the whole
first season oh my god oh here's the
whole first season here it is
spoilers I figured the whole thing out
already thwn is gonna teach Barry Allen
how to use his powers properly he's
gonna be his mentor all the way up until
the end when Barry Allen's going to find
out that thawn killed his mom and then
we're going to find out he had to to
make all in the Flash and he wanted to
be his mentor and be his friend right I
don't know that relationship that sounds
kind of predictable but then again like
with these shows like like they don't
shy away from for that right now yeah it
is I feel like that's that I mean like
look that's yeah that sounds about
right by episode three or four we're
gonna find out that he's also got speed
powers you know and by episode six or
seven the two of them are going to be
working together and I feel by the
midseason season finale there he's going
to be his mentor but we're going to
start seeing a twisted side to thawn you
know I don't know I mean that's my
that's my that's my freetail I mean
you're probably right I mean you know
like like I mean when it that's one of
the things that I'm kind of disappointed
about when it comes to comic book TV
shows is they don't shy away from
predictability yeah like you know you
get three episodes in you're like okay I
know how this is going to end but let's
just see if I'm right you know and then
you just kind of follow along to see if
you were actually right like I mean it's
not necessarily a bad thing but you know
it's like with Agents of Shield like you
know everybody was going to know well at
least I kind of figure for the most part
that as soon as Bill Paxton showed up
that he was a bad guy I was there's no
way he's a good guy yeah I mean I looked
at him because Bill P him yeah he is but
but even then like you know anybody who
sat down and and watch that like right
off the bat you get bad guy vibes from
his character like I mean you know you
look like something's going on here this
guy's not what he seems but nonetheless
I mean it's it's interesting you know
with that kind of thing but this is
where I hope that the storytelling of
The Flash will become something better
because you know sitting down and
watching some of these TV shows they're
not wildly good we had the same problem
with um with arrow and we had the same
problem with Smallville yeah Arrow
introduced Slade as Arrow's friend and
Mentor that's how they introduced the
whole first season is his friend and
Mentor but us comic book fans know slate
is not going to stay in that role ex
eventually the mask is going on and
they're going to town and the same
problem happened with Smallville they
tried to portray this Clark kentle
Luther friendship yeah and we knew
season one even if it took all 10
seasons this was GNA end with they're
going at it the funny thing is like even
the Layman who's watching the show who
know who doesn't know anything about
Superman knows that Lex Luther is going
to be a bad guy yeah at least the Aros
Wilson thing if you're not a comic book
fan you could have been like oh cool oh
my God what a Twist yeah you're right
you're you're 100% right even people who
just know nothing of Superman would have
been like isn't Lex Luther the bad guy
is the in fact they actually would be
more confused I remember being like not
being confused but I remember having to
explain to people I was like look I'm
not watching Smallville but I'm I can I
can assure you Lex Luther is a bad guy
like I'm pretty sure that's where this
is going trust me he'll be a bad guy I
didn't do much watching of Smallville
when I was a kid because that's when it
was running yeah uh but uh the thing is
is wasn't Lex Luthor doing bad things
behind Superman's back and get back the
whole time well no they portrayed it not
that he was doing bad things but that
since he knew there was a secret Clark
was hiding he was doing a lot of shady
things to figure it all out right yeah
he knew about the secret Clark wouldn't
tell him for like the first four
freaking seasons and so all all like and
it would always turn out that his dad
was doing the evil stuff and Lex was
doing the Shady stuff yeah that's what
it always turned into now back to our
topic on here where I was going before
you were asking with a Tha thing and
this is what I wanted to ask you out oh
okay at the ending of the thing on the
paper we see flash disappeared in a
crisis they State
crisis do is are we actually going to
lead to an Infinite Crisis like are we
gonna go TV shows no no no the the the
plot for the flash is he dies in The
Crisis yeah now the crisis here's the
problem though the crisis involves every
DC Superhero yeah which doesn't exist in
the flash so right well we don't know
because on that same paper we did see
way Tech merged with some other company
oh I didn't see that don't pull the
episode oh and then they've got the
Gotham show coming out Gotham's on Fox I
don't know how much yeah but I would
think that I don't know that's that's
another thing because I mean the way Fox
works with Disney and you know everybody
yeah actually what was it uh Wayne Tech
merges with Queen Industries in that
future like on that paper I'm going to
the page right now H well see that's
that's maybe they're going to make uh
Oliver Queen Batman eventually no that
that well that's the problem everyone
has with the green arrow is that's what
they did they basically made him Batman
and then season two he gets more towards
being Green Arrow instead of just being
Batman with a hoodie yeah Batman with
makeup yeah you're right way Tech Queen
Incorporated merger complete Red Skies
vanish The Flash missing vanishes in
crisis April the r Skies could be a
illusion to the sun story when
Parallax Green
Lantern takes out the
Sun so what we're what you're saying I
didn't even I only saw the Top Line
there we're basically hinting at three
possible major story lines in DC yeah
they got a lot more shows to do yeah I
don't think I don't think they're gonna
get to any of those but well also keep
in mind like Warner Brothers is doing
Batman versus Superman yes and so it's
going to guest star with Wonder Woman
and Cyborg and Aquaman so he you know
what's funny though is that was supposed
to be Man of Steel 2 and now that's
turned into the prequel to Justice
League and now we have an actual Man of
Steel 2 scheduled really they scheduled
yeah no they actually scheduled Man of
Steel 2 finally they're like no you know
what forget trying to make this here's
the thing though like if they're going
to manage to to merge those two
franchises they've got a lot of work to
do too yeah like the TV franchises and
the film franchises because they've even
out and said they're not going to do
that well that's interesting because
they said one of the movies on the
docket is a Green Lantern flash combo
movie I think that what that is not to
interrupt you but I think that in my
opinion on that one is they're building
the hype for Flash right now Green
Lantern had his name tarnished oh yeah
so I think they're going to try and back
door bring back Green Lantern in that
manner that's oh definitely but my
question is are they going to do that
guy like is is it going to be Grant
Gustin as the flash they're going to
move him into the movies I don't think
so I don't either they should I know
they're not going to because it looks it
looks like the CW universe is its own
separate Universe from everything else
the they could kick Marvel's butt if
they would just follow Marvel's train
yeah if we had multiple shows about
actual superheroes and then multiple
movies about the same group of universe
that would be incredible and they have
to stop trying to wing it and go Mana
Steel 2 no we'll do that later let's
just make this Justice League we can get
that out in two years right DC the DC
approach to movies is like the DC
approach to Comics as far as I'm
concerned it's just like well does this
work like like how many movies how many
movies is David goyer how many how many
DC movies is David goyer directly
attached to because he's attached to
he's been attached to those the three
Batman movies that don't matter anymore
he's attached to Man of Steel he's
attached to Man of Steel 2
uh he's doing the Batman Superman movie
he's going to be a creative consultant
on the Justice League movie and the
Wonder Woman movie like the guy who
wrote Blade 2 is a major writer for
those and Christopher Nolan's the
producer on those movies and it's like
it's just DC going like well what worked
like this guy worked let's put him in
charge of this even though it's
completely unconnected like but that's a
that's what bothers me you could easily
use the Nolan verse oh yeah you could
taking Christian Bell's Batman and just
said this takes place between movies two
and three yeah between these two he met
up with Superman and the Justice League
started up right they I heard they
offered Bale a obscene amount of money
really to come back to come back and he
still said no wow I mean I don't blame
him though I mean if I were Christian
Bale I'd walk I'd walk away while the
Gooding was good yeah yeah because he's
just gonna become Batman exactly and
he's not going to be an actor that's
going to be able to get roles anywhere
else and not be seen as Bruce Wayne or
Batman yeah I want to see a new Batman
I'm I'm ready I'm ready for a different
Batman what I've seen on Ben Affleck he
doesn't look that bad as I yeah looks
pretty amazing he's growing out the like
the beard now so he kind of looks
separate he's got longer hair so he
doesn't really look like he doesn't
really look so much like any Batman we
know but at the same time he doesn't
look like Ben Affleck which I'm okay
with not long Halloween Benny he looks
like long Halloween Batman no his hair
is longer than that I'd say
maybe um all right last week we touched
on this style and um and now we're going
away from the show we're going we're
going we we are we are sidest stepping
away from the show for a second for like
the 23rd okay I thought you I thought we
were moving topics I'm like there's so
much I just last week we talked about
like Ben Affleck as Batman and what we
thought you know and How likely he would
be as a successful Batman yeah so I
wanted to I want to see what you think
what do you think about that s like I
want what do you think like how do you
think Ben Affleck will do as Batman I
think Ben Affleck will do a fine job I
don't think the Ben Affleck would do a
textbook awesome job but like I've
always I've always maintained that if
Ben Affleck has the right Source
material the dude can can can can pull
it off uh he pulled off Argo I feel like
every role that he's played in a Kevin
Smith movie has been great um and that's
that may be heresy but like I feel like
the dude really like he when he hit when
he finds a Cadence he can really sell
himself as an actor um
now the thing about Ben Affleck as far
as acting is concerned is when he smiles
he becomes Ben Affleck he's got that Ben
Affleck
smile with Batman he never will so it
will really work out I think for unless
he's the first smiling Batman I mean
unless is Bruce Wayne and that I by Ben
affle like as Bruce Wayne like I could
totally see him being like hey there
Clark there are a couple times when he
laughs at the Joker's joke just to trip
The Joker up though yeah I would see
that like I I would especially if you've
seen uh the the Batman Forever movie or
the I'm not the Batman Forever movie
that was terrible
the the the Batman that's in the future
oh Batman beyond return of the joke yeah
oh that was a great movie where where
like the new the new Batman goes up in
the rafters and starts just like
laughing at him back and forth from all
over the place as he zip lines across
like that's amazing yeah bin The Joker
that was tight I really like I I love
the the Batman the Animated Series
Universe I love everything they do with
that oh God
mantion there's one dud and it's Batman
mystery of the Batwoman the directed DVD
was the first it was the First Direct to
VHS animated movie after fan after
Batman
SubZero and it was so [__] so freaking
bad like the the the voice acting they
got Kelly RI to play Batwoman and they
got that they fired the guy who
originally played penguin and it let's
not even get into it but it's it's so
bad but it's the only it's the only like
Mar on that whole Saga for me well I
just I mean we we really kind of agreed
on the thing like like we talked about
Ben Affleck and some of the roles that
he's been in like Ben Affleck in the
town was amazing like that's one of the
best performances he's ever done and it
was actually like Dave had mentioned
that um the you say it was the
director's cut or the unrated cut of
Daredevil uh I like the director's cut
it's it's the director's cut but I mean
he he did a good job in that it's just
there was there was writing problems
there was plot problems yeah you know it
was it was a fox Marvel movie yeah did
do you remember when Daredevil came out
like what what their release day was h
no it was Valentine's Day really what
why I don't know why would have they
done that well because your Devil's red
and Valentine's Day is red and I don't
know naturally the movie naturally I
took I took my then girlfriend to see I
was like well we got to go see Daredevil
now I'm sorry Valentine's day was ruined
this year so let's go wow she like what
the she's like thanks thanks for that
is there a reason why that's the then
girlfriend oh
yeah he's pretty much I can pretty much
blame Daredevil for all our relationship
issues oh okay I mean I can play darev
for a lot of things
yeah um but yeah I feel I I think I
think Affleck will do a fine job like I
don't I don't think that I'm not I'm not
one going into the theater going like oh
this is no this no like I
look Ben Affleck is the least of my
complaints with the no with the with the
uh the new DC direction of the movies
like Man of Steel for me was a was a
Calamity so I really can't I'm not one
oh I don't know about that man I mean I
was I was I was with you I was with you
up to that that's what I was gonna say
was I'm sorry DC's kind of meh but man I
thought Mana steel was pretty good Mana
Steel in my opinion did a great job of
the New 52 Superman yeah it took him but
I I mean if if you're looking for the
75th Anniversary red on the outside
underwear on the invisible Superman you
know Boy Scout I'm not going to kill
anyone no that's not the Superman we got
I was looking for our for Superman and I
got you were looking for the one you
know Christopher Reed Superman you were
not looking for new 52 emo Superman
super totally the new2 I never you know
like those movies are cool th those
movies are sweet but I was never really
like oh like this is great like I tried
watching the first Superman a while ago
like I've I've seen it a thousand times
but I tried showing some people Superman
one the other day and we were just like
let's take a
break it wouldn't work with audience
hard yeah and like the the the leaps and
decisions that they made with that like
yeah like I I'm not a you know kisses
can wipe out memories yeah exactly and
you can spin around the Earth in Reverse
time and if you Superman could grab his
s and create a cellophane net and
like you know there's all kind can do
anything yeah basically Superman can do
anything um I'm not a purist when it
comes to Superman movies but I really I
me and Brian Singer are the only guys
who liked Superman
Returns uh I really liked Superman
Returns uh I didn't like them oh my God
I have a lot of issues with it like I
the pacing was way off way too slow I
wish that there was no kid in it but but
like I feel tone I feel like the tone
the acting and the direction and the set
like everything look looked so great
like the the CG was great the Practical
effects were terrific the casting was
right on target uh it was just
like the story the story was just yeah
like yeah it was just the storye
everything about it felt great except
for the fact that Superman is now a
stalker and has an illegitimate child
and yeah and like Lex Luther you know
another real estate scheme that's going
to destroy the the Eastern SE Seaboard
like okay like as long as dark side's in
the next one I don't care like
because that's really like that's what
you do like that's what they have to do
for Batman versus Superman that that's
always that's pra okay practically every
reason the Justice League comes together
and goes we're a team now yeah I think
my my prediction by the way Batman
Superman I think it's gonna be Brainiac
or uh not Brainiac matallo I think it's
gonna be matallo you think matallo yeah
I think Matman versus Superman but I'm
wondering if it's gonna play out like
every other Batman versus Superman story
slugfest for about 20 seconds and then
they're like oh now we're friends I I
know that it's GNA deal with one of the
issues I had with Man of Steel which is
like the Fallout of Superman not saving
anybody or caring about people and
destroying half
Metropolis so I know that like that's
going to be a big plot point for the new
Batman Superman movie like Batman's
going to be like you didn't help anybody
like you half your City was destroyed
and everyone thought you were a savior
but like thousands of people died in
Metropolis when you fought that guy like
why didn't you take him to the moon and
fight there like what is wrong with you
maybe somewhere nowhere near a popular
Nevada go to Nevada we can lose trailers
I mean I know that like destruction porn
is kind of like what people are
interested in in movies now like watch
Transformers well this is my perspective
on on Man of Steel in the movie and I I
read some Superman right after I got
into Batman when I first got into comics
and yeah he is kind of like the goody
goodie once he's in the role of Superman
yeah but he's really rough in green
in in Man of Steel like he pretty much
gets tossed into being Superman in the
matter of what like two weeks yeah yeah
like he's not that's the New 52 Superman
that's pretty much how it picks up yeah
there's the whole action comic setup but
almost immediately he's fighting big
baddies with his powers and not knowing
how to use them that's how it all starts
yeah yeah
well S I can appreciate that you like
Superman Returns right but I
I think that we need to go ahead I can
appreciate you like it for the reasons
you like it yeah yeah yeah I can I can
appreciate you enjoy it but I think I
need to go on record in saying that that
you are no longer welcome on this
podcast for no um Superman Returns was
not a bad movie um I thought that Kevin
spy was an amazing Lex Luthor he was
charismatic he was interesting he was
funny you know he I know that Lex Luther
by by nature in the comics is much
darker than the way he was portrayed by
Kevin spacy but I thought that that
Kevin spy was not a bad leex Luther but
no I think he took I think I think spy
did a good job of of taking the zaniness
that Jean Hackman used and BR and making
it darker like legitimizing it I think
that that was I think that spacy infused
a good Darkness into that character yeah
um yeah I liked Kate Bosworth as as
lowest Lane though me and I think Kate
Bosworth the only ones who thought that
was was good casting choice but I really
liked her I I didn't I didn't care for
her too much I know that like lowest
Lane in the comics at least at least the
way she's tradition played it's just
kind of like this helpless Damsel in
Distress you know and Superman's always
kind of rescuing her and that's kind of
you know that's that's very 1950s is you
know 1940s 30 it's not going to fly now
but you know but overall the movie I'm
I'm the movie was just long and slow the
movie should have ended about 45 minutes
before it did
iing bother pacing do we need a
10-minute scene of Superman stalking by
floating out the window like yeah you
know what we really need is is good
writers that was kind them borrow the
guys for minute PL way back in the day
was nobody knew how to write a comic
book movie like like I was talking
before we started the podcast about how
I I saw that video of
uh man I am not good with
names just stare blankly into the camera
Dave it'll come to you Kevin Smith oh
yeah talking about Superman and how he
went through that nightmarish experience
of working with that producer oh un
writing his
script I don't know how that that could
have flown have you read that script
I I I literally just watched that video
yesterday for the first time ever it is
kind of fun really if that if that came
out in 1996 we would love that movie
really trust me because 1996 we had the
mask we had Phantom we had uh you know
yeah like we had nothing really to hang
our hat on as far as comic book movies
were concerned that like paid homage to
those movie we had Batman and Robin
like Superman's the dead super uh Kevin
Smith's Superman lives script was dumb
but it it knew what it was talking about
there's a scene where uh where they have
Superman's funeral in Metropolis and
like Batman's in it like like Smith
threw so many cameos in that movie
without
diminishing the characters like without
making it like like they're putting
Wonder Woman in the new Batman Superman
movie Why like who has time for that you
have to introduce a new Batman you have
to reestablish Superman and you have to
have them fight something and you're G
to try and work Wonder Woman in there
somewhere like I could see that though
simply because that's typically how
things always start Batman Superman
Wonder Woman but what I want to know is
why cyborg well yeah if you're G to cram
Wonder Woman in there at least that can
somewhat make sense because that's
typically how it goes down yeah but
cyborg I feel like cyborg is one of the
most shoehorned characters in the DC
lineup oh no he is it's it's like they
keep they keep basically going he's cool
we can make him cool and every time they
put him in a book I just read the newest
Justice League and the Justice League is
going on trying to find the power ring
and where's Cy up in the Watchtower
watching the monitors yeah he's
bumblebee he's Bing the base
like no uh and then they have a comical
scene with him and Shazam and Shaz he's
like Shazam you your magic to find the
power ring and shazam's like I give me
the one thing I want and boom a ping
pong table shows up and he's like all
right
well yeah since we're both totally lame
we might as well just completely waste
page
Bas I I like I like that issue though um
I did too yeah mostly for the Batman Lex
Luther conversation but yeah that was
funny he's I know you're Batman no you
don't know I'm Batman now leave yeah get
out of here you know what it is I always
love seeing Alfred with a gun like
defending the house I think the first
time I saw that was Batman Predator when
like Alfred blows the Predator away with
an elephant gun I was like this is all
Alfred's cool like I need to read that
now we've got we'll come back to that in
a minute let's go back to the Flash TV
show all of this started so the whole
part of that disc question was would we
want to see Grant what's his name Grant
oh uh
something I would love to see him as the
flash he might not be the movie star guy
we need but if you shoehorn shoehorn him
into a movie with other Heroes that
could completely work and if you could
tie these universes together that'd be
amazing oh he's not the charact he's not
the actor that we deserve but he's the
actor we need right now he would really
you know what's cool about him though is
Arrow when they casted Arrow they got
this like bodybuilder like gay porn guy
like he was in some kind of porn before
this he was he's like ripped yeah he's
some form of porn my wife was telling me
that the other day she's like did you
know he was in porn like no but I would
totally watch a green arrow
porn but um they got this guy they got
scrawnier he's not really he's tone like
a superhero would be but they could have
very easily messed this up and just all
superheroes have
muscles well he could look like the old
Flash the guy who plays his dad um where
he had like a bodysuit it was all like
muscular like the funny part was that
suit had the muscles not the old guy no
it's
true yeah no I I like it I I would be I
would see a Green Lantern Flash movie
with him in it I'd be totally fine with
that well all right all
right I know you guys want to keep
talking about Flash but I think we've
been going on the flash for about 20
2025 minutes I do I do want to ask one
last thing before we move on with it
okay because you've read the new 52 cell
and you know the flash in the history of
him yeah so you know that the Rogues
Gallery with the flash has always been
dudes with gadgets that just suck at
doing it that's the funny part about
them yeah um the new 52 reinvented all
of the Rogues they all put their guns
and stuff into that machine and got
actual Powers right now the new flag and
this is what I want to ask about because
it's my only real complaint they're
playing off of the concept of everything
is caused by this one event right flash
got his powers because of it and weather
wizard got his powers from it not he's
not using it gget he got powers from it
yeah how do you feel about them just
jumping to everyone's a metahuman due to
one event
uh if they do it right if they if it's
if it's well written and it looks cool
I'm fine like the how doesn't really
matter to me so much except for the fact
that they were like look at this map
it's almost as though they've made
exactly as many villains as they have
days that we come out with a show um as
though there is a villain of the weak if
you will um so I mean in that regard
it's kind of like all right like you're
doing that you're doing because didn't
they do with that that with Smallville
like Smallville did that for like three
seasons it was just the villain of the
week but wasn't the the the cause of it
like Kryptonite yeah for everyone yeah
it it was always like like oh this
person just conveniently got their
powers uh five years after everyone else
so we can just keep doing this I I think
it's kind of lame like I think it's I
think it's lazy but uh but as long as
they do it cool I don't care like I'm
not I'm not a purist when it comes to
that kind of thing um I kind of would I
was actually really surprised by the way
they used weather wizard I was like is
that weather wizard yeah cool I
guess and then the other question I have
and this is because my fans asked this
one well my viewers watched I don't like
call them fans I always but uh um they
were asking they un didn't like it
because they feel like it was the setup
was too convenient oh it's it was like
he's got his powers oh and conveniently
we were making this suit that is all red
and looks exactly like the Flash oh and
conveniently I'm making this thing that
will regulate your body but it's a it's
a lightning bolt you know cuz we thought
it'd be cool
yeah there's a lot of contrivances in
that but that's because I think that the
guys who were making the show are like
we don't have time to like have him
prepare like we got to just no next
episode he has to be the flash he has to
be [__] has to be freaking fighting
guys like yeah I think they just didn't
want to fall into the errow where it was
a whole season before he got the mask or
small where it was 10 seasons before he
got the cape yeah because they they're
definitely paying attention because as
we were talking about off the Record uh
we Warner Brothers released that pilot
early oh yeah our current opinion is
since it wasn't yanked down so early
it's still up you can go download it
right now go download it exactly where
hasn't
yeah it hasn't been like taken down or
strikes been put out or anything leaked
like no it's totally them yeah uh but
they're tracking the they're they're
I know that they're definitely looking
at like the positive feedback from
people watching Arrow and people being
like I like Arrow when he's a superhero
and he has a Mas on he's fighting
Deathstroke and he's got like all these
other like I like all these cameos you
know they're like okay cool we can do
that like we can get to that faster so
and I mean I mean they played on that to
a degree because they sent him to meet
Green Arrow he went to meet him and he
was like you know why would you come to
me for help you know to like cuz you can
inspire people where I can't and so on
and so forth you know yeah
well they played on that because
initially the whole concept of Barry
Allen which I think was a really crappy
backd door pilot because it didn't
actually show anything other than he got
hit with lightning but Barry Allen was
in 3D episodes of Arrow season 2 yeah
and he in he learned the arrow he
learned his his identity he learned all
this crap and then he gets hit with the
Lightning goes into a coma and he's
supposed to wake up in the pilot of this
now they rewrote it a little so that the
lightning wasn't in AOS City and it was
actually due to this particle
accelerator thing yeah but that's why
they they do supposedly already know
each other they already know each
other's histories and their secrets and
all that other crap they just skipped
all this Who's Who and we're evil thing
yeah like typical you know superheroes
oh Cameo oh no who are you we're gonna
fight oh no we're on the same side no
they just yeah they saved us that that
that was that was I like
that I feel like that's the show up that
is when like arrow goes cool and then
they end it like that's I feel like
that's where they kind of could have
ended the pilot but they were like no
let's keep it going keep it going for
another 25 minutes yeah and I also like
the fact that they decided to go with
instead of doing the basically thing
we're all used to seeing which is the
comp is friends with the secret identity
but doesn't know the superhero they just
threw that right out the window yeah
they're like no Barry Allen keep that
hood off he's gonna see who you are but
they did but they did preserve the leave
my child out of it like which yeah that
one and by the way just on just really
quick Candace Patton as Iris she's
horrible oh yeah I and I also had to
double check too cuz Iris and I I'm all
for recasting and getting more
minorities into everything espe
especially since comic books were we're
basically started in a day and age when
it was all about whites and Blondes and
I'm all for mixing things up and
changing it around now that think more
things are recepted who is who is Iris
she's his girlfriend she's like the
notorious girlfriend and she's always
been like this blonde or brown like
white girl like she's always been like
like the high school sweetheart kind of
a thing like and they're changing
everything around just like the Wally
West thing although this might be this
is l all lines into the new 52 West
Family yeah
so yeah I don't know that was something
that I kind of picked up on when I was
watching it they kept talking about the
west and that's why I asked the question
that's why I sent you a message I was
like are we going to see like Wally West
because you know I mean I know I know
Wally West is like probably is probably
the most popular form of The Flash
character like more people know flash is
Wally West than Barry Allen and people
who do know who Barry Allen is know him
because of the fact that he was I guess
the first like mainstream flash like the
first flash I'm not really sure how that
works Allen is the silver Age Flash he's
the one that first wore the costume you
all know he's not the Golden Age Flash
character no golden age is Jay Garrick
he's the one with that helmet yeah yeah
with the the things on the Sid um and
then the reason why everyone knows Wally
West though is when comic books the TV
shows and all stuff started really
picking up steam and stopped being the
we were a bunch of nerds in our
basements reading this stuff and started
being more about oh some cool stuff on
TV it was Wally West who was the flash
at the time that's why he picked up
steam it wasn't so much that no one
knows who Barry Allen was it's just that
Barry Allen was dead at that time so he
wasn't popping up anywhere no one was
talking about him it just he was gone it
was yeah Barry Allen had been dead since
like ' 86 so it's the Justice League
animated series was that Wally West that
was Wally West okay okay that makes
sense they never really came out and
showed a secret identity much so like
Young Justice though in uh in the
episode when the thanagarians take
over uh
starcross uh all the heroes all the the
seven of them they're like we have to to
hide and Flash is kind of like he's like
H I don't really want to tell you guys
my secret identity and Bruce just takes
off his mask he's like I'm Bruce Wayne
Superman's Clark Kent and you're Wally
West no no the best best one is the one
episode where where Flash and Lex
swapped bodies yes and and Lex goes in
he's like well I'm the flash let me go
find out who my secret identi is he
takes the hood off and he goes who's
this I don't know who you
are and I love that that that whole that
crossover was amazing
metat texturally because the guy who
played the voice of Wally West on the
cartoon played Lex Luther in Smallville
yeah it was that guy which is so fun by
the way Clancy Brown the guy who played
Lex Luther for some from Superman all
the way through uh justice league for me
definitive voice of Lex Luther oh you're
talking about in the in the Justice
League like cartoon show yeah oh yeah he
was he he had a he had that deep kind of
like Sinister voice Superman anim series
yeah so great yeah he was a great he was
a great s okay so just like Batman in
that anime series like those the big
issues I wanted to go over robs want to
move on now so well I just wanted to
kind of transition to new because I know
like s is a big Marvel guy so I fig we
transition into Sal's NE
of yeah yeah the problem with the Flash
pilot honestly is we could talk about it
all day because it is literally an hour
of cameos nods to the series nods to the
universe throwing and all kinds of crazy
stuff it's it's it's it's almost mostly
all that crap which might be why I got
so excited cuz the whole time I'm
watching it I'm like that's the West
family that's reverse blackag I know
what's going on that's exactly that's
exactly why it was done the whole reason
why it was done I know I can't believe
they're doing grod okay yeah hold on
hold on I your guys they're doing
they're doing in there oh my gosh how
are they gonna do that they pce by a
cage which says grod on it and it's been
broken out of and you're assumed that
grod got out yeah like a super smart
gorilla I mean I was say Rob how do you
feel about a super smart gorilla in your
superheroes I you know at this point I
come from Marvel Comics all right we've
got a 2,000 foot tall purple man that
eats planets I'm really not that like
against a super smart gorilla like I'm
really not you know I mean that's fine
with me you know I mean there honestly
there are other villains they could
include in the DC Universe and totally
screw up like Doomsday so you know I'm
I'm actually I'm actually intrigued by
this and the whole reason why I'm
intrigued is because I've always loved
gorilla Gro as a character in DC Comics
I don't know that much about him but to
me like a genius level gorilla is just
really cool you know he always has like
these super amazing schemes you know he
always like puts puts like villain teams
together and then he always fails but
you know like he's always just an
interesting character and it's just a
chance to see a break away from the
status quo of one Lex Luther is the main
villain for any kind of Superman film to
you know um something with well I guess
maybe with Batman it's a little bit
different with Batman it hasn't
consistently been the same villain I
mean you you would think that it would I
guess you could look at it and say the
Joker is the most notable villain when
you look at Heath Ledger but we've had
Bane we've had poison ivy we've had
Catwoman you know we've had whoever the
guy was that um uh what his name played
and Batman Returns you know we've had
like you know the penguin you I mean
we've had a a lot of different and
Batman but nonetheless I think that that
when it comes to DC films you know
especially Superman it's this formulaic
thing of Superman versus uh Lex Luther
and it's really really old and it's
really burned out and so I'm glad to see
the DCS expanding into characters that
you would most likely have never seen
before I guarantee in the 1990s you
never would have seen a live-action
Superman movie with with the gro you
know with with a talking smart gorilla I
mean yeah that never would have happened
so I'm glad they're into this kind of
territory there's they stayed away from
him in the original Flash show I think I
don't think they even mentioned him yeah
no yeah they never talked about him at
all there's a couple reasons I think
they're able to do this for One Thing
Marvel has gotten a little stranger with
their movies they started out realistic
and eased people into the weird stuff
like you know extremis and Iron Man 3
and some of the space stuff and the
Avengers MH and they've gotten audiences
kind of used to the weird stuff in in
comic book movies again as opposed to
The Dark Knight like super realistic
like gritty kind of you know which I was
fine with until we started getting to
the really crazy villains and oh well no
he's realistic check it out now and
another thing is visual effects have
made leaps and bouns in the last 10
years yeah they he probably won't look
so much like an actual gorilla with they
that they put peanut butter in his
mouth gorilla I want to see a real
either a man in a suit or a real gorilla
you're like CG no I want practical
effects like all those Star Wars fans
like I knew you were gonna say that I do
want practical effects like all those uh
but yeah I I want no I want Powers Booth
from the cartoon to play him again in
this and I want a real gorilla like and
he doesn't have you know what you don't
even need to move his mouth he could be
a real gorilla and he communicates
telepathically so he doesn't have to
move M and and you're already writing a
better show than they're probably gonna
put out St they're not gonna do that
and he needs to have a British accent
because everybody knows that all the
biggest super villains do what pretty
sure Gro does have one oh does he have a
British accent think he does
idea yeah all the best villains are
British British are evil I'm all of you
guys who live in the UK sty said it
before the show all the British are evil
subscribe and complain one subscribe and
compl one last thing everyone go
subscribe to his channel and put your
complaints about his views on the
British
people I wondering about
licensing one one last thing okay does
the CW have the rights to do the entire
DC Universe in their television series
yeah I'm wondering that myself because
well they're mentioning way Tech yeah
and in in the Aro show we've gotten a
lot of mentions to other things so maybe
they do maybe they have the TV rights to
live action yeah they've done they did
Smallville as well right yeah yeah me
they've got Superman in there somewhere
as I remember the only uh restrictions
they have are
self-imposed uh because
when they couldn't use Nightwing no they
couldn't use Joker in Justice League
Unlimited because they were making a
movie with the Joker in it and they
didn't want any confusion so they
deliberately didn't put the Joker into
the cartoon like Joker was in Justice
League season one and two but then when
they transitioned over Joker never came
back likewise Robin couldn't be in
Justice League because he was already
appearing in Teen Titans and they were
worried about confusion but they could
do whatever they wanted because all the
characters owned by Warner Brothers and
it's a Warner Brothers show yeah now fox
is doing the Batman
show it could be that they that in order
for like a deal that they may have
struck up with Fox is you can use the
Wayne name but you can't use Batman or
you can use Batman but you can't use any
of the Batman well see I think
with NBC isn't Gotham more
about uh the city than it is about
Batman though yeah it's about like more
like a police show it seems than it is
no one's going to watch a past through
episodes yeah they they're they they're
not because anybody that's GNA sit down
and watch something about Gotham is
gonna want to see Batman yeah I mean
well here's the other thing it's on Fox
so it will last four episodes at most
and then it will be and they'll be
played out of order we're gonna see
episode seven first yes exactly like why
is Riddler in
this okay so the the last thing I wanted
to St this isn't for you Rob but this is
for actually the viewers of this podcast
um I actually want your guys' opinion
because with the new season coming out
we're about to start getting a Marvel
Agents of Shield Season Two we're going
to get Arrow season 3 we're going to get
the flash season one um we're going to
get Constantine I wanted to know if you
guys in this podcast want us to do a
segment where we round up the weekly
shows we spend 5 to 10 minutes per show
we kind of go over our opinions what we
saw what happened and I just want to
know if you guys want us to cover this
on a regular basis once we cuz once they
come out we're going to we're going to
get a lot of shows in a week so we can
have a fun discussion every week just
half the show or a section of the
podcast discussing what happened in all
these shows and how they're linking it
all up and everything so let us know in
the comments down below would you guys
like to see a longer more involved TV
discussion and obviously we won't spend
an hour on the pilots we we'll cut them
down and go over some highlights but
yeah that's actually that's a really
awesome idea like that that sounds
really cool um all right put the record
Rob you're going to have to watch them
every week now all the DC stuff there's
more DC than Marvel I'm sorry that's not
my fault well you know what I mean if I
have to watch those crappy DC shows then
whatever well here's the thing though is
is actually there's going to be more
Marvel than there is DC eventually
because there's going to be uh Daredevil
and
Luke not counting Netflix oh come
on you know those shows are going to be
better than most of the stuff on TV is
anyways I mean I don't I don't know
about better I mean you look at Agents
of Shield and the production quality is
not the I mean you look at Agents of
Shield Season one and it's
like look at House of Cards they shot
that in 4k yeah they did and that show
is amazing but the the writing is what
makes million on that show yeah it comes
down to who they have writing up the
other episodes I mean I I love Jos
Weeden I do but in my opinion he spent
too much time weeding up the Marvel
Avengers show it needed to get more to
The Avengers
Shi in general unless I've got 13
episodes where I get to establish who's
who so that you'll feel more betrayed
later in in the it need it needed to be
more like arrow and have more cameos
yeah it needed to link better into the
universe in my opinion he weeded it up
which is not what I wanted from my
shield show my shield show you're right
I wanted more cameos I wanted more stuff
linked into it I wanted it to be more
part of the universe and shield felt
separate up until the Thor movie yeah
yeah and the tie-in episodes were
awesome
yeah yeah and they're they're doing a
lot more of though speaking of which so
I can never remember if his name is Greg
Clark or Clark Greg I think it's Clark
Greg yeah yeah so you guys know we did
an AMA on Reddit a while ago right oh
yeah and ask me anything on Reddit like
he got on Reddit my name's Clark Greg
ask me anything so is that what AMA
means yeah ask me anything
yeah so um during his AMA and this is
kind of old news but during his AMA
somebody asked him if you could be any
character for Marvel comic what would it
be and he said Captain Marvel so there's
rumors floating around that because of
what took place in Agents of Shield
because they use cre blood to bring him
back to life so on and so forth that he
could be Captain Marvel so are you guys
familiar with Captain Marvel um yes okay
oh yeah yeah yeah I kind of
want uh shout out to my girlfriend a
strong female character in the Marvel
Universe I like I like the female
Captain Marvel she she has complained
many times while watching Marvel movies
with me that they really need a strong
female character so I would want the
female version well we could just have
squirrel girl if she wants a strong
female character dude I would love to
see her even Cameo you know that' be so
awesome who is this s girl what does she
do talk to squirrels and she has a tail
yeah every furry loves her and she's got
and she's got sharp claws I guarantee
you one day she will be in Shield I
really want to see that happen yeah you
Squirrel Girl I want to see some girl
come running in there with a squirrel
tail and slashing at people with her
claws like I just want to see that
happen and see somebody see somebody get
scratched I really want them to make a
Captain Marvel movie like a female
Captain Marvel movie I would love to see
the female Captain Marvel
not not the Pakistani one that's not
really Captain Marvel at all I guess
they they could do the first movie or if
they do Captain Marvel in an invention
movie they can start it out as the male
version have it transition into the
female version I just think that would
be the perfect strong female character
yeah yeah no I agree she'd be the
perfect lead or to bring in Spiderwoman
Jessica Drew yeah well either one of
those they're doing a Jessica Drew show
that that's the show on Netflix isn't it
that's Jessica Jones yeah yeah Jessica
Jones different girl yeah that is that's
the wife of Luke Cage and that's that's
why it's all tying in together because
they they you know I mean she's she's no
she's no you know Miss Marvel but she's
still formidable in her own right in
terms of her capabilities I especially
I'm glad it's going to be on Netflix
because then they can actually like do
things with it like I was really worried
that because ABC Disney Marvel you know
all that stuff that doing a Jessica if
you if you guys haven't read Alias it is
pretty cool but it's also very like
HBO yeah yeah and I think it' be really
like on Netflix they might actually be
able to do like some really cool stuff
with that um and I like Jessica Jones as
a character I think she's really strong
and interesting and and vulnerable and
you know they could do she wouldn't be a
headlining movie character like they're
never gonna make a jewel movie but they
could do they could never know the way
they're going yeah but they could do a
really cool Jessica Jones Show but I
would love to see a female Marvel
character get a movie before Wonder
Woman just just to stick it to them that
much more be like yeah we made guard the
Galaxy and uh yeah you couldn't even do
a Green Lantern movie like and and
that's that's thing I'm just going to
say that that uh everything is off the
table now we have a movie coming out
where Vin Diesel stars is a tree yep so
and just just as I am Gro the entire
time that's all he says supposedly he
phoned it in I am Gro pretty soon
Marvel's just going to have like five TV
shows and there's going to be tie-ins
for every movie throughout the TV shows
yeah and and all of the movies are are
are going to be tie-in themselves the
other movies and yep everybody's gonna
have to watch every single Marvel movie
to understand what's going on yeah it
sounds good to me I'm already doing that
when people don't watch it then me and
Rob will get more viewers because we're
going to explain it well that's that's
that's the thing that's what I'm really
psyched about because all right so
so just for just for a second I know
Benny's going to get into the Avengers
disassembled but let's talk about like
the Scarlet Witch for a second the fact
that Marvel's doing all this stuff like
we have Luke Cage and we have Daredevil
like we have all these TV shows coming
to Netflix I think we're gonna see an
Avengers disassembled event coming up in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I think
we're gonna see a point because you've
got
um uh Chris whatever his name is I can't
remember his name name anymore but Chris
Evans no Chris Evans yeah he doesn't
want to do Captain America movies
anymore he's like I'm I'm done playing
Captain America Robert Downey Jr is
another projects with Robert Duval and
he doesn't want to really do Iron Man
that much anymore and so you've got
these characters who have really kind of
like set the foundation for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Marvel's going
outside the status quo by doing
Guardians of the Galaxy where they're
going to have a a character like you
guys said I mean Groot Maximus the Mad
the brother of blackp so that Groot is
apparently so smart that when he talks
all we can understand when he says is I
am Groot even though he's saying like a
multitude of other stuff but Maximus was
also crazy too so nobody knows if that's
true or not but like yeah like the fact
remains that we're going to we're seeing
like all these events unfold and I think
you're going to have like all these
characters who have set this foundation
and that eventually they're going to
leave I mean I think the Captain America
is going to be assassinated I think
we're going to see this post Civil War
event where Captain America gets killed
I mean we saw we've seen crossbones set
up in the um at the end or I guess
during the uh winter Soldier film you
know so I think that crossbones is going
to kill him now whether or not we see
Sharon Carter actually the one that
pulls the trigger to you know to to give
the killing blow I'm not really sure but
I think that we're going to see um uh
cap or Captain America go away I think
that Robert dney Jr they're just going
to kind of write him off however maybe
it's some kind of post Age of Ultron
he's the one that created Ultron kind of
thing his alcoholism moves him out of
the picture I don't know how they're
going to do that and real quick with
that one that's easy to fix they just
they just the Robert Den jior Iron Man
thing is an easy fix
Iron Man is in a full body suit if
Robert Diner Jr doesn't want to do Iron
Man movies anymore you still have Iron
Man you just
easily else in a suit iy could easily
like if they didn't want to make him
take the m i I don't think Downey's out
entirely it's just my concern is that
he's like he's he's getting old and he's
not gonna want like he they're gonna
basically make a decision at some point
where they're like okay Downey's gonna
come in for the
close-ups like he'll be a and he can
show Tony Stark he'll just make a cameo
basically as himself and that that seems
to be fly around and he I can tell like
Robert Downey Jr still really likes to
make Indie movies yeah like he doesn't
he doesn't really like you know the big
budget like crazy like you've got to be
on a set for like three four months and
yeah you know go through hell basically
to make this movie but we're going to
pay you $50 billion
that's the thing he does like that he
does
like and well I don't think anybody
would complain about I'm in the wrong L
of of course then there's Chris Evans
yeah I mean that's that's what I'm
saying like you know I think that we're
going to see an Avengers disassembled
kind of thing going on post Age of
Ultron and then I think we're going to
see like a new Avengers setup but that
begs a question because the new Avengers
were led by Tony Stark and Captain
America yeah you know and so you know
what are they are they just going to get
rid of him enti and are we just going to
have like a new Avengers being led by
you know I don't know Wolverine
Wolverine I mean he it going to be led
by Clark Greg as as Captain Marvel as
Marvel I mean I don't I don't know what
they're gonna do with that I mean I
don't I think they'll just I think
they'll just recast you think so I think
yeah I think I I don't think yeah I
think the Marvel's too too focused on
money for them to like just go oh well
how can we make it fit they'll just no
just recast I mean they did it three
times in Hulk yeah I don't want them to
do it but I I know that but yeah they do
it with Hulk like they'll be like yeah
no the the reason why I don't think they
can do a recast on some of their major
characters is they built the franchise
off of keeping the same people playing
the roles yeah so so I think they would
find a way to to kind of move out of
those after after they do three or four
movies with each character they're going
to transition into something else yeah H
actually I got to agree with style on
this because even if the movie started
pulling half of what it was making it's
still like a major smash Blockbuster hit
yep yeah I mean Iron Man one is one of
the most successful films that Marvel's
ever produced and Captain America the
Winter Soldier is the most successful
film they've ever produced if they've
just did half oh yeah it's a new Captain
America okay so so what would seem
better to an audience to recast somebody
as Tony Stark or to have Tony Stark pass
off his mantle to somebody else that
makes sense um I'd say get rid of
probably yeah they would probably just
say I would say get rid of him because
fans would like that more just to move
on yeah but in my opinion Marvel's just
going to go what would be the cheapest
way to do oh yeah we won't pay Robert
jener Jr to even make a cameo in this
movie and we're just gonna pay this new
guy yep and we'll we'll lose half the
people that watched it because we
recasted but whatever that's still like
you know2 200 billion dollars not only
that but like I don't want to see that
because I know what Marvel will do when
they make those kinds when when they
make a movie decision they try to carry
it over in the Comics because they think
that people are coming from the theaters
to read the comics and they're not like
no sales proov that one so they really
think like but they but they still tell
themselves that's what's happened so
like if they had if they had a movie at
the end of like Avengers 3 where Tony
Stark says well I think I'm gon to be
done being Iron Man but maybe this young
guy might be Iron Man in the comics Iron
Man will retire and they will replace
him with some young guy like they will
do that uh and I don't want to see that
because they don't have to age in the
comics so
and it'd be so obvious it'd be so like
yeah you just did that because the movie
did that like the Spider-Man organic
webbing like well he has organic webbing
in the movie and it'd be confusing if he
has like this one random thing so we'll
change
that yeah you know no I agree with you
on that and they need to stop going into
that kind of a thing because they're
half ass of doing it yeah they're not
they're not full on doing it and then
linking it to the movie if it linked to
the movie cool I'd be behind it but the
fact that it doesn't link to the movie
and they half ass make them all match up
like when they did The Avengers
assembled comic book that was supposed
to be the cast from the movie but it
wasn't the full cast from the movie they
still threw in random extra people and
mixed up everything and they threw in
Thanos which made no freaking sense
because he technically wasn't supposed
to even be around at the time no I think
he was in the cancer verse or whatever
yeah yeah that see that that was one of
the things that that drove me up the
wall like people like you had you had
Thanos you had Peter Quill and you had
Nova who were locked in the the cancer
verse after the events of the Thanos
imperative and so Marvel kept kind of
going back and they come kind of kept
saying well you know we're kind of
hinting to the fact that Thanos is going
to return and it's like Thanos is back
and no one knows how and so they are
that though the the next issue of
Guardians of the Galaxy is all about
that thank God man because they' just
been dragging it on for month after it I
think it's the one after that it the
cover is by the guy who drew uh the
first volume of Guardians of the Galaxy
when uh I don't remember who was writing
it when they like relaunched it oh okay
the uh Annihilation Conquest as my
friend call it the Guardians of Iron Man
guardians of Iron Man Okay okay so so
let's talk about the Guardians of the
Galaxy for a second so so for those of
you guys who are watching this and don't
know who the Guardians of the Galaxy are
are not familiar I've got a video on it
but the short run is they had an event
called Annihilation Annihilation
Conquest some really bad mojo happened
this crazy guy called Nyla showed up
wanted to eradicate all life blah blah
blah blah they stopped him Peter Quill
came along and said we basically need a
galactic version of The Avengers to keep
stuff like this from happening so they
form the Guardians of the Galaxy so on
and so forth so anyway um without a
doubt hands down I think the one
character from Guardians of the Galaxy
that's going to steal the show is Rocket
Raccoon like people people are already
hyped up for his character because he's
so badass like he's awesome in the
comics I love his character in the
comics he's unique too like he's a
unique concept to anybody who hasn't
read yeah yeah he's a cute raccoon that
that a badass he's not a
raccoon don't make me repeat myself
he'll kill
you
I mean he's he's a he's a bipedal
raccoon that was given that was given
enhanced intelligence then what is he if
he's not a raccoon I don't know he never
says he just says I'm not a racon
raccoon called one yeah he just do
called one because rocket was I think it
was taken by the cre and then
experimented on but he was I thought
there was a whole race of them no Rocket
Raccoon yeah he's he was a raccoon and
they experimented on him and they made
like they gave him like B bionic
enhancements and Hyper intelligence and
he escaped like I think it was the cree
SC around life well no he was originally
like they originally did they set his
character up now unless they've retconed
it if I remember correctly they set his
character up so that he was supposed to
be one of several individuals that was
guarding like some planet for the
criminally insane or something like that
and uh they gave him artificial
intelligence stuff so that they could
basically just like leave monitoring of
this planet to whatever indigenous
species they just dropped off there or
whatever species they left there so um
now that I could be wrong about but I'm
I'm I'm feel fairly confident that I'm
thought I remember but I haven't read it
as recently not like they they may have
they may have changed it because with
the movie coming out they may have said
well that's just stupid and so they just
made it something different but like
nonetheless like yeah he's a bipedal
raccoon who never misses his Target and
actually one of the coolest scenes uh
one of the coolest uh instances with him
is during the Thanos imperative when
Thanos like when they when they
ReDiscover Thanos and he's just Mindless
and crazy and totally rabid um what is
it uh Rocket Raccoon is talking to him
and and basically tells him if you don't
calm down like we're going to drop you
into gravity well and your your
punishment is going to be infinite life
which of course is like the worst thing
that Thanos could endure is living
forever so uh it was it was like this
really really cool scene and then Thanos
calmed down and they F they were finally
able to rationalize with him and say
like like there's some guys coming
through a rift in space that want to
kill us all and Destroy Mr Ste like we
need to stop her so or stop those guys
so um but but that that's that's the
thing you know um I'm I'm curious where
they're going with Thanos because for
the most part no one knows anything like
no one knows anything about where
they're going with Thanos we've seen
some infinity gems we see Guardians of
the Galaxy so we know there's going to
probably be a big event that takes place
in space we've got the Avengers surely
The Avengers are not going to be
confined to planet Earth doing any event
that involves Thanos so it's probably
going to be this great big huge space
fairing event they're tipping our head
to the cre we see the novacore like we
see all these major things taking place
and so you know I'm sure at the end of
this or at some point along the line
we're going to have this great big huge
you
know I guess Universal wide battle but
you know I don't know what direction
they're going to take it I mean they
can't do the thano or they can't do like
The Infinity Gauntlet cuz I've been
thinking about that The Infinity
Gauntlet story wouldn't make any sense
in in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
right now and the reason why is because
there's no one that's been been
presented to us that could stand against
Thanos with the infinity gaunet like no
one you know I mean there's there's not
a maybe that maybe that's the movie in
itself though I mean maybe that maybe
that'll be the introduction of a
universe Cosmic character maybe Captain
Universe will show up or something like
Adam Warlock or Adam Warlock warlock or
Mt Jim Jaspers or Mt Jim j i mean you
know and even during The Infinity
Gauntlet story line like no one really
stopped him per se he just kind of ran
drunk with power and said I'm one with
the universe and then nebula took the
took the gauntlet off his hands and then
she went crazy so yeah you know that's
what I mean like they could still do it
they could yeah just because we don't
have character they can defeat him yet
does not mean that mean that heck that
could lead up to some a whole another
series of events because they made the
Avengers because of the alien attack
what what are the Avengers going to do
if they can't stop Thanos they're
they're they're going to scale it up
again maybe that's why the Guardians of
the Galaxy and the Avengers have to come
together I don't I don't know I mean
I've just I'm not seeing anyone that's
been presented the Marvel Cinematic
Universe who is who is just so wildly
powerful that even if Thanos didn't have
the Infinity Gauntlet they could pose a
reasonable challenge like I mean we've
seen Thanos absolutely stomp Bruce
Banner in the incredible Hulk like we've
seen him pound him into the ground like
he took on Bruce is the Incredible Hulk
and I think um who else he took on like
oh Drax the Destroyer yeah he took down
Drax the Destroyer like he took down I
mean he withstood a full scream from
blackbolt like blackbolt screamed in his
face and he just like smashed his face
into the ground during the say that they
won't tear like tiar his power down
though I hope I hope they don't I hope I
do not want to see this as an early you
know Jim Starin run of Thanos like I'm
I'd be so mad think the reason why we
don't have any Cosmic characters cuz the
Guardians of the Galaxy it looks like
we're just getting the normal guys in
the universe we're not getting cosmics
is I don't think they want to run into
the Superman syndrome where I mean and
Marvel has the same problem there are
heroes in DC and and Marvel that are so
freaking powerful that anytime something
happens you're just like where the hell
was the super duper powerful guy yeah
why didn't they show up and in comic
books it's easy for us to just knot it
away as s says they just go oh they were
busy over in sector H doing you know but
in the movie universe you're going to a
larger demographic and everything has to
make sense to a certain extent so if
Marvel introduces their Cosmic superp
powerful oh my God character why is that
guy not just showing up and stopping
everything right I mean we're already
kind of half seeeing things Shield is
completely going down and burning
everything is dying and where was Iron
Man during this entire thing yeah yeah
we're already kind of getting that same
question of you know where you know the
the the Bruce ban thing Bruce Banner
they they last Hulk movie actual Hulk
movie was dealing with all kinds of
crazy stuff and they're destroying an
entire city and you mean to tell me that
you know Bruce ban I mean Iron Man
didn't fly in they didn't send in
Captain America to fix that you know
yeah so we're already kind of running
into this so if you add the cosmic level
character then it's a question of why
didn't they blink and show up I mean and
even in the comics you see that like my
Subs have been screaming at me my my
fans been screaming at me about Franklin
Richards saying like we want Franklin
Richards but Franklin Richards is a
perfect example you've got a a
12-year-old kid that could
just or 30 that could annihilate all of
existence just like that you know with a
snap of his finger and he's he's so you
know demig God kind of powerful you know
God level powerful and yet he pretty
much never shows up I mean like I mean
you've got the Civil War event you know
when Susan storm bails on Reed Richard
like I'm going to join Captain America's
side and you've got Johnny Storm playing
with Valeria and uh and Franklin
Richards like the little kid could end
it all like he could just stop it all
yeah you know I mean you've got huh oh I
was goingon to say did you read that
article I don't remember who published
it but like it was recently Frank
Richard syndrome yeah well the whole
universe is affected by him yeah why
nobody ages it's because Franklin
Richards doesn't want anybody to die
yeah I read that where everything fine
until the 60s and then it just got all
wibbly wobbly Doctor Who style that's
why like no one knows that they're not
aging like I'm like yeah that sounds
good to me supposedly there's there's a
theory for DC but I can't find the
article they mentioned in that article
they like it doesn't even make you know
this isn't even close to how crazy the
DC theory is and I'm like What's the DC
theory yeah
exactly well and I think another thing
is once you get to that like tier of
power things like certain things become
less important to you yeah you know like
like for example like Franklin Richards
I I can compare him to probably uh um Dr
Manhattan from Watchmen he after the
evenge of
Watchman he's just like why am I
bothering with this simple crap yeah I'm
going to go off in and be in the
universe and actually make use of my
abilities yeah but the the the doc Mr
Manhattan is is a to we could easily get
a super I mean Superman's a great
example he's super powerful and he's
still in it does every little thing that
happens unless it just doesn't work for
the story
right I mean that's that's the thing
like that's that's one of the big
questions people have you know about
Marvel and I guess they have about DC
too is why even introduce a character
that could make that could do anything
with anything you know that that
basically can do whatever they want to
why even introduce them if you're going
to have like big stories I mean you have
you have yeah like the war Kings all
right Sally you rais a good point you've
got like Vulcan who's head of the shiar
Empire at the time right yeah I mean you
you you know and you have him going
against the uh is it the cre or the
Scrolls I can't remember thought it was
the Scrolls but I thought the SCS home
world was eaten by Galactus at that
point so they were kind of scattered
okay so maybe it was a cre buteless like
you have have Vulcan versus uh some
other you know some other individual and
um the problem here
is you have all these major conflicts
taking place you know how do you stop
like why have a character like Franklin
Richards that could just end it all
right you know like like why even have
that character because in the back of
your mind no matter how crazy the story
gets you know no matter how insane
things get no matter like how hopeless
the conflict is you know that there's
one guy that just snap his fingers and
it all comes to an end yeah and and why
does that's the point I was making like
and I think that's why we're avoiding
Cinematic Universe because what I've
noticed in the Cinematic Universe is if
they don't have to explain it they don't
want to no and that's that's like the
old that's the old Joe Casada uh excuse
when uh when Casada told strazinsky
to undo the marriage uh
sosinski had Mesto uh no had them go
back in time and they he had this whole
like he he plotted out this whole like
butterfly effect in one event changed it
changed all these things that allowed
the marriage to go away but everything
else work and have it all make sense and
uh cada's like no just don't explain it
just just just just just no just say
that that went away and that's it and
stroinski says like no but it's ma if
you're using magic it has to make sense
and cada's line is It's Magic we don't
have to explain it yeah right so it's
like if that's the mentality over there
like you know if it's magic and I don't
have like we're use that we we allow
magic to be however powerful or however
not powerful it is and and it's just
it's just convenience it's a story
element that's all it is and it's it's
like the Cosmic Cube The Cosmic Cube for
the longest time is just the answer to
whatever we couldn't explain yeah yeah
that's that's all it is yep I mean the
scol which was the same way you know
which I guess kind of leads into the
house of him because I know we said we
we talk about the house of him but the
scholar witch First shows up and she's
part of Magneto's crew the original
Brotherhood of evil mutants and she was
like well we're going to do some hexes
and stuff's just going to kind of fall
in our favor and then we get to the
House of M and she warps reality you
know and now she can rewrite reality
yeah now she can rewrite reality just
you know it's just didn't they say that
the reason for that was she got granted
some additional power or something for
that one incident uh no that she she
always had like that power just kept
evolving and evolving and evolving and
evolving
just gr she was
justful they wrote it off at some point
that she was so powerful due to
something at that point and now it's
gone well in House of M like the reason
why she's able to reshape the world is
because she uses her powers in
conjunction with Professor X's mental
capabilities yeah okay that was yeah she
combined oh yeah that's right because
she yeah she had take yeah because he
was the first one to vanish and I guess
she had taken him or something I can't
remember that yeah cuz there's a there's
a shadowy scene where it's her
Quicksilver and Professor X and
Professor X is like sweating and
screaming so like you're like oh I guess
she's using him in some way I don't
think a really explain how she used him
but uh whatever yeah I mean I don't I
don't know so so I guess to to jump to a
to jump to an older story which is
actually a kind of theme that I like is
talking about like older story lines in
in Marvel and DC like I like that idea
so to jump to like a to a story line not
too long ago to the House of M um I
would love to see some variant of that
take place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's just really kind of
Wishful Thinking at this point but the
introduction of the Scarlet Witch would
be really kind of awesome because the
Scarlet Witch was just always kind of
hinging on crazy and then she fell off
the deep end and so I'm really hoping
that like with their introduction as
like Miracles whatever it is maybe the
experiments or whatever it is that Hydra
did on her to really kind of like give
her the powers that she has are really
just kind of like contributing to her
sanity eroding over time you know I
don't know if that'll be the case or not
but I think that would be a really cool
thing because the house of him gave us
the chance to see characters that we
just wouldn't Norm see them like you
know we saw Wolverine and Mystique
banging each other you know and Emma
Frost and cyclops were together and at
the time they weren't you know at that
point in the comics they weren't so you
know it was it was really kind of a cool
thing to really kind of see it all come
together and to function that way but as
I understand the House of M wasn't just
it wasn't confined to earth like the
house of him I thought was confined to
like the like that entire universe as a
whole uh I know that they speculated
about it in the in the comic itself like
mhm and McCoy are like we don't know
like how far it reached like even in
Avengers disassembled like when the cre
attack and the and shield can't see the
cre ships on their sensors but they're
there and they killed Hawkeye and stuff
you ask or they ask themselves like how
far did Scarlet Witch's Powers reach
like did she pull people from the cre
Empire to fight did she were they were
they F like you know were they just
Visions like we don't know the reaches
of her power and of the effective House
of M so yeah I don't know well a lot of
things that happened to Marvel leave
that back door so that later on if they
want to explain something they're like
oh that was because of the House of M
event 2008 yeah yeah yeah go buy that
book for
$150 it's man it's one of the best
stories it's one of the best stories
before we really dive into this how long
this podcast been running Rob because I
feel like we've been chatting now for
close to two hours and I know we last
week so we have an excuse but and we're
going to say that Sal just talks a lot
yeah blame it on me I mean I mean the
viewers said they like having longer
podcasts so oh I know but I don't want
us to exceed like four hours especially
when we're not week we're not even
remotely close to that and I know I'd
like to prepare better for House of I
know the viewers want like they they've
wanted uh discussion on the House of M
for a long time and I think they've
wanted like this round table style
discussion of like the House of M where
they just want is like talking about it
so I mean [__] man give them what they
want right well
that's itself could become something
that we talk about more in full next
week or this turns into a three-h hour
podcast yeah no I mean we're we've been
talking now for two hours and 15 minutes
by my clock and I got to leave in 45 so
oh okay I do as well yeah um all right
well I mean we can save the house of him
for next week I we can bring s back on I
know you're dying for it Rob but you
have to admit The Flash pilot takes
precedent over the 2008 storyline it
does but it was a great it's it's is my
favorite storyline in Marvel Comics I
love the house of him it's my favorite
story line he we'll hit it I I will 100%
hit it all right well we we'll bring
salon next week and uh we'll bring them
on next week again and we'll talk about
the house of embit um but yeah so I mean
I guess Rob real quick can you ask S if
s can come next
year down you guys want I'll be happy to
come back s didn't want to come like I'm
not coming back next week know just I
just way before this podcast we're like
May or maybe not we didn't check for
next week and Rob's already like next
week s will be back and it's like did we
check with s like an in from me like no
it's screw you sounds good to me guys do
not say that
again um but yeah I guess I mean if
we're at the two-hour Mark we'll go
ahead and and wrap this podcast up but
um again you know if you guys want to
see the whole debate between s and Benny
you know they were talking about um
Azrael versus the Superior uh superior
Spider-Man which was the Dr Octopus or
was Dr Octopus having possession of
Spider-Man's body then uh you know head
over to IC story in and check that out
and uh and yeah I guess that kind of
wraps it up I mean you know again s you
want to give people the rundown on your
channel let them know what you guys have
going on over there don't we still need
to talk about original sin oh yeah
original sin well Benny says that we've
been talking long enough and that we
need to bring this podcast to an end we
also said that why you gotta do why you
gota be me why now all the viewers be
down below be like that [__] it's all
about [__]
Ben
I don't get my three-hour podcast
because now it's not
Dam because before this we only went to
an hour and 15 minutes and and Rob I can
say all I want I want a 12-h hour
podcast but I'm I'm not might not watch
a 12h hour podcast yeah I I have a 40
minute show on Thursdays called Dak
issues on TV little house and we what
Shameless whing I just did I'm sorry um
by the way it comes out every Thursday
THS you get a new episode 40 minutes
between 30 and 40 minutes it's at
youtube.com TV littlehouse yep yeah
people that don't get a long enough
podcast here because of Benny yeah go
over to
myny yeah but just just remember guys
it's TV littlehouse youtube.com TV house
it's a great channel it's it's this
thing TV little
house I yeah I like I love the content
you Little House on the Prairie get rid
of on the Prairie add TV to the
beginning TV little house and by the way
if you look up little house you will not
get TV little house you will get Little
House in the prairie
yeah um but uh I I have a lot of people
who like the show who are like oh I
loved last week's episode haven't
finished it yet but I love and I'm like
it's 40 minutes like really [__] on your
lunch break man Rob will do Civil War in
a 2hour thing broken down in the four
videos I'll do Superior spener 1 through
31 in 12 minutes so that's the level
of we could do uh we could do quick
initial thoughts about original sin like
what do we overall feel about it um I
had it pulled up um you know I'm on the
fence about the direction has gone so
far um the idea that Nick Fury's been
using lmds all this time H you know lmds
have been played out but there could
just be that they're just kind of poking
fun at the fact that Marvel uses lmds as
a scapegoat for Nick Fury stories
whenever they ride him into a wall so
yeah you know here's my question about
that why are we going like this this
whole event to me so far feels like a
let's bring up characters that no one
has any questions about or like Watcher
he died oh we're gonna give him a
history well I didn't care about the
Watcher you know we're bringing back the
orb who the hell cares about the orb and
now they like and now we're going to
explain Nick Fury even further and I'm
like were there questions about Nick
Fury
like I mean The Watcher the only real
purpose The Watcher ever served was one
I mean he was mysterious and to a degree
I would have liked to learn a little
more about him but the only time I ever
really care about the Watcher is when he
appears in the comics CU it's like okay
like some really big stuff's about to
happen like that's that's really like
Marvel telling you like things like
something really big is getting ready to
take place that's really the only Tom he
ever shows up and that's really the only
reason he needs to show up you know it's
just to let us know that like a major
story is about to take place I did love
original sin number zero by Wade uh that
explained the Watcher story I never
really cared about the Watcher backstory
but reading that I was like it's really
nice that was that was a good story like
that was really well done Rob and I
disagreed about that like I agree with
you it was a Well story but here the
question I like Rob and I both agreed
that we like the Watcher as a cosmic
entity that is just mysterious and now
you're making him humanized and he makes
more sense and you're like I don't why
now now he's just a guy who had a whole
bunch of families and was a part of a
race that yeah yeah get I don't
understand why we needed that we didn't
need it it was a nice story but we
didn't need that about the Watcher yeah
well it was a way for that I think it
was just their way of a selling an extra
book and B being like okay The Watcher
died who
cares yeah like yeah let's try and make
it so that someone might care and I'll
be honest like they uh they made me care
a little bit more I was like I as
opposed to him being a plot device I was
like oh it's too bad like they're
pushing it even further though now now
The Watcher had a kid and now like
they're really oh no you really should
have cared about the Watcher even though
we've never really done anything with
him but it's but it's like what they've
done so far is unnecessary fluff like we
had um moon dragon and we had Gamora and
we had Bucky Barnes flying around the
cosmos you know and they're like oh my
God there's we're in like we're seeing
like a dead Planet you had Punisher and
Doctor Strange who are going to other
dimensions and they're like why are all
these monsters dead they've been gone
for a long time and then Nick Fury pops
up and says hey I'm really old but ever
since the 1960s I've been traveling
around killing all these monsters and
stuff I mean it's just not like it's
it's not what I was hoping for you know
when when I read the last comic book and
they revealed that Nick Fury is old the
infinity formula is no longer effective
and every version of Nick Fury that
we've seen since the 1960s has just been
a life model decoy that includes Nick
Fury from Secret Invasion that includes
Nick Fury uh the secret War Yeah the
secret War Nick Fury secret war that
every appearance that Nick Fury's ever
had is just a life model decoy and it's
disappointing that they're they're
taking it in this direction they could
have done so much great stuff with that
you know but this direction you want to
talk about bs directions from or
original sin how about the fact that the
Avengers are currently travel traveling
through time again yeah
again now we're going to the future but
that may not necessarily be a bad thing
because they keep they jump they jump to
like sporadic years you know and they
they jump to what is it they jump to 50
years in the future and 45 years in the
future and then they went another like
hundred or something they eventually go
to where Ultron wins again anyway right
yeah and and all that's really done is
to just set things up for Age of Ultron
coming down the line so people will
remain interested but nonetheless you
know I'm I'm just you know this is one
of those story lines that Marvel is is
creating where I feel like it could have
been amazing yeah like it could have
been really good I mean seeing the
Unseen you know the Watcher you know
what happens with people having the
Watchers eyes and we still don't know
who has the other eye at least to my
knowledge we don't know who has the
other eye so I don't think so at least I
found it I mean it it could become a
really really cool story but up to this
point I'm not really happy with I'm
seeing right I'm just kind of
disappointed with the direction the
Marvel's taken it's just kind of become
what could have been it's it's what
could have been a great story and it's
kind of become a mundane Story I mean
there's a reason why I had to get caught
up on Civil War and I didn't just read
it the week it came out so see this is
why like you guys you guys give me a
hard time for not getting single issues
but now you've invested what
$4 what a week roughly into this book
for the last five or six weeks a smoking
habit yeah
and you're not happy with it well I can
go oh this event wasn't any good I'm
going to skip this one but but David if
we don't support the books coming out
now you won't get books later to read
boom I don't think that's
true they' had the original sin hard
cover planned since before original s
what I'm saying is if nobody buys the
individual issues they'll NE they'll
stop making individual issues and then
no books will come out of that I I
you're right the hard cover is gonna
come out no matter what but if sales dip
we lose books yeah or at the very least
we'll get like a story that's just kind
of shoehorned into an ending and it'll
just kind of be crap but that's true um
anyway with that being said um yeah I
guess we'll go ahead and kind of wrap
this up um are you sure Rob I mean yeah
we we could hours to be like no no it's
okay Rob we can it's not whether I'm
sure I'm down for going for another hour
talking some more about the house of him
but Benny says that he's got stuff he
needs to do I gota go buy comic books
like literally that's like that's what
I'm going to do is buy comic books I
mean you um but yeah I mean we've gone
on for two hours or so and I I think
it's it's good enough to go ahead and
and yeah call it a day but are are you
sure Rob are you sure sure I'm sure are
you positive I'm I'm confident in this
statement are you positive yes
okay End video just right there just end
it right there all right did we did we
give Sal's outro plug I don't think we
did uh we gave him we gave him a ton of
but I can do another one sure why not
goes just in case nobody's heard it at
this point ex if you don't know TV
little house by now you never will but
if you don't uh come to youtube.com
littlehouse or littlehouse online.com uh
it's where I do my magic uh for those
you wondering he basically does what Rob
and I do but he does it explaining it
imagine if you were all in the room with
me as I explained a video in comic story
and and you had no idea what's going on
that's what s does he does people who
don't get it yeah with mine's a little
bit with a little more contempt I think
uh I'm remembering it you know yeah it's
it's yeah so we got a number of shows
back issues off the rack bonus round
busted and uh yeah so what what what
frame of mind could you possibly be in
that you never read Age of Apocalypse
what's wrong with you I read Age of
Apocalypse when it came out I don't I
don't have a copy of it yeah uh I don't
have a copy of it to to draw from like I
would literally be like okay so Legion
and then I'd be like and then some stuff
happened and then they undid it yeah I
have a request for your next episode
okay final crisis final crisis okay oh
God no look it's on the list man I gotta
I want to see you explain that to Ethan
and Ben it's I I mean I feel like I have
just by being like so there's this Omega
sanction uh let me actually really quick
like this is my list right now I've got
like this list on my phone
oh I've got a massive list myself all
the request you just write them down and
go okay yeah there's a guy really wants
World War Hulk I'll probably do that at
some point um the max I'd like to talk
about at some point uh The Avengers JLA
crossover the clone saga Kingdom Come uh
preach oh Kingdom Come such a good story
yeah oh yeah um explaining just aliens
in the Marvel Universe are you gonna do
justice H Justice that's another good
Alex Ross Justice yeah I know Ben has
read that so I I'll have to I have the
absolute addition of that I love it so
much ni well next week I'm putting out
my final crisis comic story video so we
can kind of like have a crossover thing
you know here's this now watch him try
to explain it himself the two people
have no context for it so it's like okay
so there's these new Gods
uh have my script for that final crisis
video so far half that script is
explaining before final crisis yeah you
have
to okay Infinite Crisis but before that
I go to ah how do you get your friends
to do this they uh they like um well
because it we this this was inspired
from literally just them asking me
random questions like I'd have books
like lying around the house and they'd
come over and be like what is this and
I'd be like oh well here's the here
here's the the comic yeah and that would
lead to more question and that would
lead to more questions and more context
that needed to be explained um so yeah
like and so I was like hey why don't we
turn the camera on and actually just
make the show out of this I mean it was
it was an awesome idea man like like I
love the videos that you guys make like
they're they're entertaining but yeah I
mean I I feel you man like explaining
comic books can be a challenge sometimes
like it's just like cuz you know like
I'll sit down and make my videos and
it's like how can I explain this from
the perspective of somebody that doesn't
know anything about it and it's hard to
put yourselves back in that shoes you
know back back in those shoes again it's
hard to like put yourself in a frame of
mind where it's like I don't know
anything about this storyline you so
it's it's it's kind of difficult to do
but but yeah I the same problem exact
same thing I'll be writing up a script
and I'll be sitting I'll get halfway
through the script and I'm like does
this make any sense and then I have to
go like back to the beginning I'm like
okay what I got to explain this and I
got to go over this now and I actually
send my scripts over to the guys that
you're in the same chat but I send it to
a group of people who don't read Comics
but are interested kind of like kind of
like Ethan and Ben for you and I go read
this do you grasp it right are you
following me so far like yeah yeah I
mean that's that's the same thing I did
with Civil War part 4 I sent it off to
him it was like let me know if it
doesn't make any sense and they were
like I mean sounds good to me so I was
like good enough upload and you follow
along if not we have to start over yep
but uh okay so so for the for the actual
like for real and for true we're GNA
wrap this podcast up okay but um but
again you know if you guys are
interested in in uh you know the whole
idea of again you know comic book
explanations if you guys are interested
in video game discussions if you guys
are interested in kind of you know these
Roundtable reviews of you know comic
books that are that are new and fresh
than TV little house is where you want
to go I mean you know s has some really
really really good content on his
channel um we definitely want to have
him come back and and let us know what
you guys think you know let us know what
you guys think about this this whole
podcast you know because we like having
Sal here we'd love to have s back and
again we'll have him back next week for
um you know our house of him discussion
and uh and yeah be nice to have someone
who understands DC so that way when I
start going into DC R it's not just me
talking in the
how long has been going on about
DC 15 minutes now we wind this back to
Marvel
yes but um but yeah so so let us know
what you guys think and um you know I
guess you know for the the last tidbit
um again you know I'll be continuing
Civil War we are at part four so we're
over halfway through so we've got you
know 5 six and seven we've got the
tie-ins so we'll probably have that
wrapped up here in the next few weeks
hopefully fingers crossed by the
beginning of August so um that that
series will be finished from there we'll
transition on to probably uh the House
of M within a month after that when
Benny gets done with Avengers
disassembled and maybe some individual
stories between that time period um but
yeah so what do you guys have going on
on your channels coming up um over a
comic story in I'm actually because I've
been doing my week break right now um
I'm officially coming back I did put a
video out today uh well yesterday not
putting out this this one today but I'll
officially be next week um I'm going to
launch a two know your universes
explaining what the new 52 and what
Marvel Now are and why they had happen
as opposed to just just saying all the
time that they got new 52 or Marvel now
um I'm also going to bring out the final
crisis story line finally and I'm going
to begin my Guardians of the Galaxy
month every week I'm going to explain
one member of the current team of
Guardians of the Galaxy and we're going
to end that by going over the first Arc
in which Iron Man joined up in as David
liked to joke about uh the Guardians of
Iron Man
so um I'm also I'm also going to start
over the course of this month I'm not
sure when but we'll start going in the
direction of House of M so we can link
together with Rob here so and uh what
I've got coming up uh is more Civil War
I'm doing my like seven part like hard
cover Series right now to show people
kind of how to collect what Rob is
talking about uh I'm not sure uh you
guys might be able to help in the
comments what video I should do next I'm
thinking about either Frontline or
Spider-Man and keep in mind that they
they collect more
than finding says but like Spider-Man
people
question Spider-Man because I I've got a
lot of people who question what order
read Spider-Man and buy the stuff yeah
the the problem is is the Spider-Man
hard cover is out of print and it is
also like House of M
$150 but you could look this up you
could buy all the D slot run stuff for a
lot cheaper and paperback yeah probably
he's been well he's been doing it since
like issue 600 or something now yeah
yeah Dan slot's been going a while all
right so that's what I've got coming up
on my channel what about you
s uh well we just came out yesterday
with our Nightfall episode of back
issues uh this week we are doing a uh
we're doing we're reviewing on off the
rack Superman number 32 Aquaman number
32 and original sin Hulk versus Iron Man
number one and uh I never really know
what episode of back issues we're going
to do until we do it but I'm teetering
on World War Hulk um but maybe secret
War I'm not sure uh it really depends on
what we have in the store that I really
really want to talk about um good enough
so yeah I know that I know we really
should do Infinity Gauntlet at some
point yes yes man you got to do ombus
the Omnibus for that is actually coming
out actually it has officially come out
as of the first they released it earlier
than than was originally projected I
guess
so good stuff all right guys well um
yeah I guess we'll we'll see you guys
back here next week we'll have S again
and like I said we'll be doing House of
M and we'll try to get more topics
sorted out and uh yeah so we might even
do like a viewer Q&A if anybody wants to
do something like that they can just ask
do live we could do it live I've got a
twitch Channel already set up that I
horribly keep to that schedule
on supposed to be streaming every night
at 7 p.m. that never
happens um but yeah so uh yeah we'll
catch you guys later all right have a
good bye